[Music]
we are breaking into programming to go
to Israel where the parliament has
approved the first part of controversial
judicial changes it includes limiting
the power of Supreme Court's judges this
bill forms part of a wider package of
changes that protesters have been out on
the streets demonstrating against all
year critics say the bill is a threat to
democracy let's go live now to our
correspondent Mohammed jamjum he's
joining us live from West Jerusalem and
as expected Muhammad Parliament has
ratified one of the contested laws
limiting the Supreme Court's powers
foreign
that's right that very contentious bill
has now passed out we have gotten
reports that the opposition has left
members of the opposition in the knesset
have left the building there are reports
that they did not vote on that third and
final reading of this bill they wouldn't
have had to have voted for it to pass
because of prime minister Benjamin
netanyahu's far right wing Coalition
well they have four more seats they had
the votes to pass this all along the
question throughout the day was was the
Prime Minister going to try to afford
some kind of a compromise with the
opposition there have been high level
talks all day behind the scenes the
Israel the Israeli president Isaac
Herzog has been practically begging the
prime minister to try to come to some
sort of a compromise of the opposition
to soften the language of the bill that
apparently did not come to pass we
should tell our viewers a little bit
more about this bill this is a bill that
would limit oversight of the Supreme
Court basically it means that the
Supreme Court would no longer have the
power to overrule government or
ministerial decisions that it deems
unreasonable that means that oversight
powers of the Supreme Court and other
courts in this country have now been as
critics say substantially weakened as
you mentioned this is just one bill that
was voted on today it's part of a larger
package of proposed laws by the Prime
Minister and his far right-wing
Coalition Partners these laws were first
proposed several months ago and
everything came to a head this past
March because those proposals were so
contentious and so controversial and
there were hundreds of thousands of
people that kept coming out onto the
streets and because it was a general
strike well the Prime Minister then
shelved that proposal but then in the
past couple of weeks compromise talks
between the Prime Minister and the
opposition broke down the opposition
walked away from the table they said
that they did not believe the Prime
Minister was negotiating in good Faith
well right now we're in a situation
where the knesset is going to go on its
summer break at the end of this month
the Prime Minister was under a great
deal of pressure from his far right wing
coalition to try to pass at least one
part of his proposed overhaul of the
Judiciary as you mentioned critics of
this bill and the larger plan have said
that this was substantially weaken
democracy in Israel they are really
worried about what this means to that
end let me just mention the protesters
that have been out all morning their
numbers they're only increasing in the
last hour they are very loud and
boisterous right now they knew that that
vote was ongoing they are extremely
upset there had been some hope in the
last few hours that perhaps perhaps
there would be some way that the Prime
Minister would be convinced to step back
from the brink that because of the
pressure he's under not just from these
demonstrators there have been hundreds
of thousands of demonstrators throughout
the country demonstrating the past week
but also because he's come under
pressure from members of the reservists
in Israel's military who said that they
will not report for duty if this bill
were to pass so right now this country
really in crisis very polarized and the
demonstrators say they're going to keep
coming out no matter what happens going
forward and as you've mentioned Muhammad
prime minister Netanyahu has come on to
immense pressure this year but the fact
remains that he's been able to this bill
is passed because he has a parliamentary
majority we've seen hundreds of
thousands as you've been reporting of
protesters out on the streets all year
every weekend of this year but what are
the opposition's options now do they
have any
foreign
the opposition had tried every way that
they could to um to try and delay voting
on this bill uh it just didn't come to
pass for them they didn't have the votes
at the end of the day now there's a lot
of talk right now in Israeli media and
among political analysts here right now
that perhaps because of interventions
from the president and other
high-ranking leaders in this country
that perhaps the Prime Minister would
try to forge some kind of compromise and
add amendments to this bill going
forward that could soften the language
and it it wouldn't limit the oversight
as much as had been proposed initially
but look this has now passed it passed
its final reading so essentially the
Prime Minister doesn't have to but if he
doesn't and if he just keeps going
forward with this plan it does seem as
though more demonstrators are going to
continue to come out they're very very
angry the opposition is angry
um but the prime minister is under
pressure for members of his government
and Justin the last few hours it was
reported that members of his Coalition
had said that if he essentially steps
back or softens the language or adds
amendments that they don't agree to that
they would then walk away from his
government and that would mean that the
government would collapse so it's a very
tricky time right now it's a Time
everybody I've spoken with here today
say that they've never seen a time when
this country was in more of a crisis
they were extremely worried about what
this means for democracy going forward
so many of the people that I've spoken
said they believe that this puts the
country onto a road towards autocracy so
it's very worrying for everybody who's
out here but at the same time they say
they're going to continue to come out
and oppose and they're going to push
opposition parliamentarians to try to do
whatever they can to keep the Prime
Minister from going forward with his
additional plans
and Muhammad that's been said that if
this part of the changes were passed and
they have been passed on Monday the
other sections of the bill will be
easier to pass hasn't it
well that's really an open question
right now Elizabeth because there were
even more controversial parts of the
proposals of that the Prime Minister
essentially had to take off the table
and um essentially what's happened is
that the Prime Minister knew that there
was so much opposition that he was not
going to be able to pass this package of
proposed laws in one go and so what he's
done is he stepped back and then he
started breaking up uh the proposal and
seeing what he could pass and that's how
we got to where we are today he wanted
to get this bill passed that bill has
now passed but there are other even more
incendiary parts of that proposed
legislation there was one in particular
that angered so many just a few months
ago that would have if passed
essentially allowed members of
parliament to overrule Supreme Court
decisions as we understand it that is no
longer on the table but might it come
back on the table in the days or weeks
or months to come we really don't know
the prime minister is in a bit of a bind
right now and he's trying to balance a
lot of the pressures around him the
demonstrators keep coming out they are
extremely angry the military reservists
they are very angry and that puts this
country into even more of a crisis
because you've had military leaders the
past few days say that the fact that
over ten thousand Reserve this across
different branches of the army now have
said that they won't report for duty if
this bill passes they say that that
impacts the military Readiness and
preparation of this country so that
could essentially cause
um you know problems if there were a
security threat that they perceived
going forward so it's really going to be
a delicate balance obviously for the
Prime Minister but
these demonstrators who are behind me
and there's more coming up this road and
we expect to see more in the coming
hours they're just saying this is
unacceptable to them they're going to do
all they can to oppose any plan the
Prime Minister has going forward to try
to overhaul the Judiciary any more than
he already has yeah something that they
have repeated all year isn't it Mohammed
thank you very much for that for now
that is our correspondent Mohammed
jamjun joining us live from West
Jerusalem
we're going to stay with us now and
bring in Marwan bashara he's Al
jazeera's senior political analyst and
he's joining us from Paris on Skype good
to see you Marwan
um is this what you expected
well it wasn't actually clear you know
you would think that the voice of reason
would uh you know would end up on top
and that the country cannot afford to
continue with the same paralysis that it
seems like it's going through now and
the same divisions and Chisholm that
apparently paralyzing much of its
cultural political and the economic life
but clearly those in the coalition
government think differently than the
voice of Russia now they think more in
terms of power and authority they think
more in terms of ideology and fanaticism
they think it's their chance and they
clearly don't want to miss this chance
certainly don't want to postpone it for
another 15 months
as the opposition leaders were proposing
they think it's their chance to pass one
important piece of legislation that will
enable them as individuals I'm talking
about people like prime minister
Netanyahu who have been indicted on
three different charges I'm talking
about
one of the main Coalition leaders the
head of Chas who's been indicted and
imprisoned on tax evasion but want to
become Minister of Finance these sorts
of leaders within the Coalition
governments have just now passed an
abusive legislation that will allow them
to serve open-endedly regardless of any
objection from any branch of the
Judiciary including the Supreme Court
so in the midst of this uh controversy
if you will I think there is a real
sense that the corrupt leaders
of this Coalition are making sure that
they will disable democracy and the rule
of law in order for them to continue to
rule within Israel will the Israeli
public stand for that though we've seen
the kind of opposition and we've seen
the opposition all year to these
protests
they're not going to go away are they
it doesn't seem like it in fact they are
doubling down and they're doubling down
in a way whereby it's not just
individuals it's not just the thousands
what's more important in a country like
Israel is that institutions are joining
in meaning you know the 150 plus
important corporations the high-tech
industry uh some parts of the uh the old
Army Reserves and the former generals
and and the trade unions and labor
unions and so on and so forth all these
are very important pillars of the state
and the facts that they are joining in
uh the protest movement against the
ongoing efforts by this Coalition
governments to end
uh democracy as we know it for the
majority of Jews within Israel it is a
clear sign that Israel is of course up
to a major storm in the days weeks and
months ahead but that's what's coming
regardless of whether there was or was
not a compromise today because Israel is
divided between let's just call them for
the time being for the sake of brevity
and for the sake of clarity to our
viewers around the world let's just say
Israel is divided Israel as the Jewish
State that's been in a state of War its
entire life
is now divided between hardcore generals
and fanatical rabbis
who will win the rabbis or the generals
for many years the rabbis the fanatical
rabbis and the generals have coexisted
but over the last few months and since
this government was formed with five out
of the six parties making the Coalition
being religious
of the most radical kind the
ultra-orthodox or the ultra Zionist
Ultra conservative five religious
parties are making sure that they're
going to block the Supreme Court from
objecting to their rulings and they want
to transform Israel into a Jewish
autocracy perhaps even a theocracy if
they can and in fact Elizabeth yeah they
have been saved
all right mud one thank you very much
for that no doubt we will be coming back
to you over the next few hours that is
our senior political analyst madwan
bashada